so a couple of years ago i started
running art competitions on my youtube
channel there was one for sakura for
elden ring dark souls demon souls and
bloodborne
and the art that was created for these
competitions was so incredible that 11
months ago i decided to run a
kickstarter for a book that i wanted to
call soul arts i wanted to showcase more
art i wanted it to be showcased in a
better medium than youtube and it was
also a further excuse to compensate all
of the artists that were involved
and now almost a year later the finished
product is in my hands and i kind of
can't believe it i can't believe i'm
holding this right now thanks to your
support we really did pour everything
into this book and it's just layered
with hard work and meaning soul arts is
printing right now i'll show some
footage of the printing process i love
watching those machines work
but it's cool also to imagine it being
shipped out to kickstarter backers as
well as we speak but it's also available
to everyone for purchase so if you order
soon you might actually make it into
that first round of shipping i'll leave
a link to the store in the description
and if you're interested right now i'd
love to showcase the book to you and
just finally talk about some of the
design decisions that went into making
it
so first off i'd love to talk about this
slip case
there are a few reasons why i knew i
really wanted to do a slip case for soul
arts first and foremost it just gives
that intuitive feeling i think that the
book inside is something worth
protecting which is a feeling that i
really like
on top of that
literally it gave us an extra layer of
design elements to add to the book so
these five glyphs for example each
correspond to the art competitions and
the chapters of soul arts there's one
for each inside each one you can see a
symbol that corresponds to the winner of
each of those art competitions which is
a cool detail
credit to andrew hind for designing this
slipcase but another thing i knew i
wanted was a window
i think that a window gives a really
inviting view into the cover behind the
slip case which in turn invites you to
open it and explore the book a little
bit more
the circular symbol here was
necessary i thought or the best shape
for a window in this cover because
circular symbols are all over dark souls
and elden ring and bloodborne
like the moon the dark sign the elden
ring so i knew that was the shape i
wanted to go for and it just works so
beautifully
showcasing these characters
at the top
of ricardo and mikey's beautiful cover
art
so this is ricardo amike's stunning
cover art for soul arts it features this
tangle of grey limbs this tower of
bodies that descends all the way down
past an ethereal canvas that all of the
artists struggle to paint upon the name
of this piece is we may be but small but
we will die a colossus which is a line
of dialogue from dark souls 3 and it
really speaks to the individuality of
these artists but also
the joint venture that they're all
drawing upon
ricardo is just so talented let's look a
little bit closer and you can see his
mastery of lighting and anatomy
and
every single one of these characters is
unique they're all a reference to the
kind of creature designs that from
software themselves create
and even up till today i'm still finding
little references in here that stunned
me like i knew this was a dark souls one
dragonkin kind of creature but then i
realized it actually has as a paintbrush
the dragon tooth
from dark souls
another favorite is this corvian
creature here who has
these splayed paint brushes
like a claw
and ricardo is just so incredibly
talented and all of these characters
continue all the way down into the
darkness where unfortunately some of
them are hidden from view
that's one of the meanings of this piece
to me it represents how unfortunately
some artists couldn't be included in
soul arts and couldn't make it into the
art competitions
which was basically the biggest tragedy
for me when creating this book and the
most difficult thing for me so very
meaningful piece i'm sure you can get
your own meaning out of it as well but
without further ado let's crack this
open and have a look
[Music]
so when you first flip open soul arts
you're immediately greeted by these
gorgeous golden end papers which feature
hundreds of little symbols that are all
references to the artwork in the pages
to come
and i love how
these endpapers are present on the side
here as you flip through the book but on
this opening spread we had to include
the painted world which is
probably my most popular piece of
merchandise there are hundreds of little
references in here to dark souls demon
souls bloodborne and sakura if you get
close enough and i hope a lot of you do
look for all the meaning that we've sort
of layered into this book but even if
you don't i hope that subconsciously you
still feel that that meaning is there if
you look closely at the blurb you'll
find a link to an unlisted youtube video
where i narrate every single word of
soul arts so that you can listen along
to my narration as you flip through this
book but then we reach our first chapter
which is the sakura chapter and here we
have this stained glass window design
where every panel of the window is
actually a design
from the chapter to come so in that way
this is literally a window into the
first chapter
so the thing that's unique about the
secular section is that all of these
designs are of weapons artists were
tasked with creating new prosthetic
tools for sakura to use like the
pivoting great sword where sakura can
sheath his katana into a greater blade
and then wield that large blade in
combat which would have some serious
ramifications for secular's core combat
but i think it would still work one
thing that's important to remember is
that all of these designs were created
before secular was released so they're
all extremely original as a result
like the mantis blade which is in its
folded form here but then it can fold
out
and be seen in its true horizontal glory
we have a bunch of these fold out pages
throughout the book they're double-sided
as well and they allow us to showcase
certain pieces you know in the format
they were supposed to be seen
another thing i love about these is that
a lot of the
designs have these little diagrams that
show what the actual animations look
like and that helps to draw you into the
image and then if you really want to
learn more you can read the descriptions
that i've written for them where i talk
about gameplay and folklore and a little
bit more detail it's another one i love
the karasu claw where sakura attaches a
sticky bomb to an opponent after
grabbing them then blasts them away
where they explode in an aoe burst and
just imagining how these would be used
is a lot of fun
this is the kamaitachi a serrated saw
that runs along a rail
the karasawa which is a reference to
armoured core the kunai harpoon which is
a stealth weapon where you can reel
enemies in from a distance
chopsticks everything is in this book
everything you could ever want sakura to
use
the moonlight greatsword of course
um
the thing that's so fun about this is
that every chapter is unique but even
within each chapter because every page
brings you a new artist with a new art
style and a new design
it's a very you know
refreshing new experience with every
page turn and i think that makes the
book a lot of fun to explore
[Music]
at the core of the elden ring chapter
are the boss designs which artists were
instructed to create based on what we
knew about the upcoming elden ring and
like in the sakura chapter these bosses
benefited from the fact that we knew
very little about the game they're so
inspired like hearn the hunter which is
a boss that stalks you as you progress
through his section of the open world
firing arrows at you from afar and
motivating you to flee his domain
a lot of bosses lured you in to their
section of the open world where they
would fight you
and
some of these are so inspired like the
naki lavi by andre sherstuck which made
use of the fact that we knew eldon ring
was going to have mounted combat so this
enemy fights you on horseback and you
can choose to dethrone the rider or kill
the horse and whatever you decide that
will influence what happens to you in
phase 2 and phase 3.
such an incredible design
another big aspect of this chapter was
the fact that entries were supposed to
be based on nordic folklore or some sort
of folklore in that region and you
really see that come through in some of
them like in starchild by daniel
knoblich which is this monochromatic
photorealistic rendition of a fairy tale
which
i really enjoyed writing about and
reading about
and that was really my main job with
these was to
write stories this is another favorite
sorry i have to talk about it this is
the knockin by gregory holmes which is
this unassuming silhouette seen in the
ocean which draws you in curiously or
maybe you're drawn in by the loot on the
shore
but when you get closer
the giant monster is revealed underneath
and this is what fights you this is what
drags you under the water and engages
you in underwater combat
which didn't make it into elden ring but
there was a time where we where we
believed where we thought things like
that might exist and that's what's
special about this chapter is that these
artists really captured a snapshot of
what it was like waiting for eldon ring
in this next chapter we get to explore
the unseen lands of dark souls and while
some artists decided to show us places
that you know we hear about in dark
souls but we never really get to see
many artists alternatively decided to
show us places that we do get to see in
dark souls but that we don't really get
to explore back when they were in their
former glory this for example is izalith
and it's riddled with demons but you can
still see the traces of their
civilization you know in its heyday as
gwyn and gwyndolin walk through this
place to meet with the mother of chaos
herself
this is such an imaginative piece but
then you have again you have jugo which
is a place that we don't get to see in
dark souls but has been rendered here by
zen cloud as this giant ant infested
arid wasteland with these almost
horrific towers that actually um
abandoned ant mounds
these are where the remnants of
civilization live up top and then down
below they defend themselves against
raids from the giant ants which just
feed their civilization basically and
ironically the ants
attack their civilization but they rely
upon them for food and for armor and
things like that so just a hugely
comprehensive piece by that guy
jugo is actually the favorite piece of
another youtuber who has got their hands
on seoul arts i'll link his showcase up
here
this youtuber is named adam duff he's
one of my favorite youtubers he is a
great destination if you're an aspiring
artist or you're an artist or you're
just someone looking for general
wholesome life advice i hugely recommend
that you check out his channel he's a
very wholesome guy
speaking of wholesome actually this is
katarina by nolan 192.
this is a place that from software would
never let us explore it's too damn happy
nolan has shown us a katarinan dungeon
here and within we can see people
eating dancing singing
still working off their hangover from
the night before
such an imaginative piece i love that
one
another shout out i want to give is to
andrew hind who is responsible for the
layout of soul arts
myself and andrew had a lot of debates
about which piece to include where which
piece to put in the book in the first
place
you know how to arrange them what order
what size they should be in a lot of
thought went into that and i can't thank
him enough for all the hard work that
went into that aspect of the book
as we head into the demon cells section
i want to quickly recap so for sakura i
wanted artists to create weapons for
dark souls it was landscapes for elden
ring it was bosses but for the demon
souls section i wanted artists to be
free to draw whatever they wanted as
long as their creations occupied the
realm beyond the sixth broken archstone
of demon souls this place is called the
northern limit and it features in cut
content
from that game so here we have a boss
the iron baroness who is inspired by the
shadow men of demon souls which we knew
featured in that content here we have
the great ravine which features giants
and men
and it's an area that had its ecosystem
forever changed when a giant explosion
rocked the area and led to
the rise of scavenger tribes who took
over this area
here we have the weaver who occupies the
twisted city which is this creature that
exists in sort of like a dreamlike world
that she weaves into being
we have you know very sort of
horror-esque renditions of giants we
have
you know these remnants of a war against
the giants which is what the astray
knight depicts it depicts this man
commander hute
who fought in the war against the giants
you know with his sword for killing
giants and a sword for killing men he
has a fantastic story uh this one this
one is like photorealistic it's just
it looks like it's an in-game shot right
i don't know how some artists create
this digital art it's incredible i
decided to tell the story of this one
through item descriptions
which might be a lot of fun
writing these stories was actually a lot
like writing stories based on dark souls
you know i had scraps of information and
i pieced them together and tried to tell
a story about it which was a lot of fun
as we dive into the bloodborne section
of this book i might go on record and
say that i think bloodborne might just
have the most insane the most cultish
fans of any from software release and i
mean that as a compliment because i
think that attitude extends to
bloodborne's artists as well look at
this piece for example this is an entry
by thomas chamberlain keane
and he creates not one not two but seven
incredible pieces of art that all serve
his narrative that take you through the
world of ailing lauren and i should
mention that the goal of the bloodborne
competition was to
imagine bloodborne 2. no matter what
form that took whether it was a
landscape or a trick weapon or a boss
these artists really did
go all out and another one i really want
to draw your attention to is this this
is ocean born by toby travel jar
and it has our hunter venture into the
depths of the ocean except that ocean
has been effervesced it's evaporated
and so you're exploring these
depths and all the eldritch creatures
that have been brought to light
within and
i mean just look at these
[Music]
it's just
basically the basis for an entire game
right there
in a few pages and
i could keep going but really i think
this book is best experienced again not
through youtube but by holding it in
your hands by flipping the pages by
going deeper and looking close up and
reading the narratives that are inspired
by this artwork so i hope you decide to
pick up a copy remember you can get it
from the link in the description or
additionally you can listen to my
narration of this book over on youtube
if you can get that link at the start of
the book
but on that note i also want to mention
that i will be narrating the entirety of
abyssal archive which is two enormous
books made by the same publisher of soul
arts and these two books are dedicated
to the law of dark souls so if you want
to listen to me literally talk about
dark souls lore for hours on end then
please check out this project in the
description below its pre-order campaign
is live right now and this law is
written not by me but by loki who has
helped out with a lot of my videos and
he's one of dark souls most dedicated
scholars so again you can pre-order with
the link below and it should start
shipping at the start of next year so
don't miss out but before i go i want to
give a huge thanks to john devlin who
was with me for every single judgment of
every single art piece that made it into
this book and that made it into the art
competitions john was with me every step
of the way helping me judge artwork
which is like a futile endeavor really
but we did our best and i couldn't have
done it without you man
ricardo amike he helped judge a couple
of pieces so he has his own interview
alongside john here at the back of the
book
ricardo was a part of every single art
competition he judged a few he created
artwork for pretty much all of them i
think
and again
you couldn't do it without the artists
they're all listed here in the artist
index go to this page as you're reading
soul arts find these artists go to their
art station pages their portfolios
commission them give them work
you can tell they deserve it honestly
and lastly thank you to the benefactors
of soul arts who supported the project
on kickstarter and thank you to tunin
fairweather who published this
beautiful book
you